making fun of the media and then they're
doing exactly what we J thank you for
the plot ideas this is nobody nobody
beats the Babylon be they had they wrote
that article and it said uh woke
activist and and skin head try arguing
but end up agreeing on everything and
then someone was like Babylon Beast
strikes again and there's an article
saying like why are neo-nazis joining
Pro Palestinian protests yes speaking of
that Ryan long and Danny polishuk video
where has like the hardcore racist guy
and then someone who's like in BLM every
opinion is exactly a line it's was so
great welcome to the modern era man yeah
what a crazy time to be alive it is a
crazy time to be alive and I think
that's the thing that I love about
people who don't really engage with the
news is like they've got enough on their
plate they they can probably tell you
everything that's going on in their
Hometown in their office they know
everyone's birthday because their brain
is not occupied with trying to keep up
with everything I think it's important
to be engaged and be aware on the other
hand I'm sure people who are obsessively
following the news miss all kinds of
things and they're personalized you have
to have a balance